- What is the value of completing an MBA?
since I graduated from
the INSEAD MBA in 2016,
I got asked this question a
lot from family and friends
on my Instagram channel Firm
Learning and the last day
I also posted several pieces
on my learning journey,
my reflection on what I
took away from the MBA
and there was well I
received lots of questions on
whether it's actually worth it
to complete an MBA in these times.
In this video, I'm covering
the top five reasons
why I believe an MBA
might make sense for you.
So I hope this helps you
to evaluate for yourself
whether doing an MBA
might be worth your time
and your money.
Hi there my name is Heinrich
and welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
If you are already a subscriber,
I'm so grateful that
you're following me here
on this YouTube journey and if
you're not a subscriber yet,
if you take any value out of
this video, please consider
subscribing and also
hitting the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
So what is an MBA program?
So for those of you who don't
know, just let me give you
my brief personal definition of it.
The MBA stands for Master
in Business Administration.
It is an academic degree.
But the big difference
compared to many other master
programs that exist in
business, especially in Europe
is that it is a post experience program.
This means that you're usually only able
to get into the program
if you have several years
of work experience.
So typical MBA program
would have an average
work experience of their
class of four years.
So the average person who
attends an MBA will have four
years of work experience
and usually the bare minimum
that you need to have is two
years of work experience.
And this is often also
only possible if you come
from a so called accelerated
career environment,
which is to pretty considered
either consulting or banking.
Where you're assumed
to just have collected
lots of experience in two
years so most of the time,
if you come from a more
regular industry background,
you will be expected to have
at least the full four years
of experience before you
can enter the program
and the second key difference
to the more traditional
business oriented master programs.
As they exist, especially in Europe,
is that why these master
programs are usually more focused
on preparing you for an academic career.
The MBA is more professional degree
that is supposed to help you prepare
to become a manager in the
real world if you wanna
to put it this way, right?
So really to prepare you
to succeed in a business environment,
and not in a specialist role,
but more in a general management role.
And so before I talk about
the reasons why I believe it
could make sense for you to do
an MBA, let me cover the top
two reasons why you maybe
should not do an MBA.
And these two reasons come
down to the investment
that you need to make when doing an MBA.
And this investment consists
of both time and money.
So if we look at it at the
time aspect of things and MBA
program usually takes
either one or two years,
with some programs in the middle
and what you would typically
see as the US programs
are on the longer side of the spectrum,
so rather on the two years side of things,
whereas the European or
International programs are more
on the one year side of things.
Though of course, there
are some deviations
from that rule in both directions.
And of course, you need to
realize that one to two years
are a significant time investment.
Instead of doing the MBA,
you could work on your career
in the job that you're currently having,
and also advance in this job
in this one to two years of time.
And you need to be convinced
that by doing an MBA, you
can actually accelerate
your career so much that this
loss of time will actually
be recovered later down the path.
And the second element of the cost.
If you currently look into how
expensive an INSEAD MBA is,
this is the program that I competed.
It currently costs about 85,000 euro
for the one year MBA experience.
So I was lucky that when I completed it,
I believe it only was 65,000 euros.
So you can see that the cost of these
programs rather tend to go up over time
and I also had the privilege
to get some funding from
my employer at that time,
but many other didn't needed
to pay the full amount.
When you pay for such a
program you need to consider
that not only you lose the money,
but you will in this time
period of the MBA in these
one or two years, you also cannot work.
So you're losing the salary,
the income for this time period as well.
So it's kind of a double
cost because you need to
pay for it on one side, and
then also lose the salary of it
on the other side. So doing
an MBA can be quite expensive.
And again, you need to
believe that then later down
the road, you recover the cost
due to an accelerated career
development and a higher
salary that you incur,
which you wouldn't have got
if you wouldn't have done
the MBA.
So is there any basis to
believe that you actually
can recover this investment?
Well, there are many rankings
of MBA programs out there. One
of the probably most renowned
is the Financial Times MBA ranking.
And in the current 2020 edition,
you see Harvard Business School on one,
Wharton of the University of Pennsylvania
on number two, the Graduate
School of Business from Stanford
on three and the INSEAD program
on number four in the
global ranking.
And in these rankings,
you typically see how
salaries and other KPIs of the alumni
of these programs developed.
So if you don't look
into the Harvard figures,
the program ranked number
one, you see that the average
salary of the alumni corrected
for purchase power parity.
So the weighted version lies
around 210,000 US dollars.
And this is supposed to
correspond to an increase compared
to the pre MBA salaries of
110%. Just for your information
in this financial time ranking
this is measured by looking
into the salaries of the alumni
three years after completing the program.
For the INSEAD MBA the
numbers are a bit lower,
on average alumnus would
yield a salary of 181,000 US
dollars, three years after graduation,
which would correspond to a
salary increase of 101% compared
to their pre MBA salary.
Of course, now the Harvard MBA
is two years while the INSEAD
MBA is one year so the return
on your investment regarding
time is even higher now
for the INSEAD one.
So looking at this, yes, there
seem to be some plausibility
that after doing these kind of programs,
you salary can be boosted to level high
enough that it actually
justifies the time and the money
that you invest upfront.
But be aware that this is only a spectrum.
So while it might be
worthwhile for many people,
there will still be a
certain group of people
doing this MBA for whom
it didn't really work out
as they hoped.
And of course, these are
some of the most renowned
some of the flagship
MBA programs out there.
There are many, many other
MBA programs which have KPIs
that fall short and of
course, you need to be aware
that these programs are some
of the globally leading ones.
And it's not guaranteed that
you get admitted to them,
you need to show a certain
level of professional
and academic performance
in order to get admitted.
So you might be stuck with
one of the lower tier programs
and the stats of these programs
usually are not as good
but then on the other
hand side of the cost
also not as high.
So now we talked about
two more obvious things,
time and money and why
this is super relevant,
and probably most people
already think about if they ask
themselves whether they wanted one MBA.
In this video, I'd like
to cover five reasons
five advantages that I
got from doing an MBA,
which I believe are less
obvious or maybe less clear
to many of you who think about doing that.
So I'd like to cover
this in this video now.
And of course, now I forgot
one of the biggest advantages
of doing an MBA. And this
is that you're going to get
all kinds of great and crazy shirts.
I mean, look at this amazing
sports shirt off the INSEAD MBA
this is what you would get as well.
Doesn't matter where you do it.
But now jokes aside back to the video.
So let's start with number one.
And this is looking at the
MBA as some kind of Joker card
that you have.
After the first years of your career,
you might find yourself already
kind of stuck in a certain
box in the corporate world
maybe you're an accountant
or you're a controller
or you did lots of marketing and sales.
And you're afraid that
if you just continue
your career, the way
you're currently doing it,
you will be just so
stuck into this position
that it will be really
difficult for you at some point
to transition into a completely new role.
So one of the reasons
that people do an MBA for
and I found out by looking
into my peers in the MBA
that this works really well
is to make a bold transition
into a new role.
And if you think about it, conceptually,
most people think of doing
these kind of conditions
in three dimensions, you
can either transition
to a new geography, or you
can transition into a new
industry, or you can
transition into a new function.
So regarding geography, maybe
you currently work in Europe,
and you'd like to make the
transition to work in Asia
on the US.
So doing an MBA can help you with that,
or you would like to change
industry, maybe you've worked
a lot in automotive, and now
you'd like to work for retail
or for healthcare.
Again, doing an MBA can be helpful to you,
or you'd like to change functions.
So currently, you worked
a managerial accounting
or you've worked in production,
or you worked in marketing and sales,
and you'd like to switch
to another function.
So it doesn't matter which
of these three dimensions
you would like to change.
The MBA is like a joker card
that you can pull out once in your career,
and it can help you to
make this transition.
Because on the MBA, you
get exposure to all these
new sectors, all these new
fields, roads, you can take
new courses that are relevant
to the new role that you'd
like to take.
And all of this will help you transition
into your new field.
The only thing that many people
will give you as an advice
is to not try to change
all these three dimensions
at the same time.
So do not try to change
the geography, the industry
and the function at the
same time if you're looking
to do a transition after the
MBA, but try to keep at least
one of these three dimensions constant,
and try to only change two of them.
Because experience shows that otherwise,
you will have quite some difficulties
and the change is just too much.
But of course, if this is
what you really want to do,
there's always a way to
make these things happen
if this is what you're really after.
So the second reason is
regarding the type of content
that you learn and what does
this thing to have about MBAs
is that because they do not
have so much in academic focus,
they can focus much more on
teaching your practical skills
that you will not find in typical
other university programs.
So as I am someone who has
already studied business
in an undergraduate level,
so the business degree
from the University of Munich
and then I even have a
master's degree in finance
from the London School of Economics.
So even for people who
already have business exposure
in the university fields,
it is true that if you do
an MBA, there will be some
repetition because the MBA
program does not assume
that all the people already
have a business background.
So teaches you foundational
courses, which will be some kind
of repetition if you already
have a business degree,
but the truth is then that
later on there will be lots
and lots of courses,
which you will likely not
have had in your regular
standard University undergrad
business degree.
So to give you some examples at INSEAD
there were courses
offered or negotiations.
So how do you negotiate and
we did lots of role plays
with professional negotiation coaches
to improve our negotiation skills.
We had a course on corporate turnarounds
So how would you actually handle a company
a situation where the company
is in too heavy financial
distress, and you will
need to turn around?
What are the implications
of that? How do you behave
in this kind of context as
a manager, and of course,
lots of courses on entrepreneurship
on building businesses
on identifying new business models,
and many other aspects of
it. So this is really hands
on experience that you will
not get in most other more
academia focused master
or bachelor programs.
And this is what is so
special about the content
that is taught at an MBA.
The third reason for doing
an MBA is the network
that you build.
And this is a bit of a cliche point,
there are people out there
who claim that getting
and building a network is
one of the main reasons
to do an MBA so while I
wouldn't necessarily agree
with that, I agree that it
is one of the key advantages
of doing it during your
MBA program, you will have
the opportunity to build
friendships and deep relationships
with the so many of your classmates
and there will be
friendships coming out of it
that really last your whole life.
And when you choose what
program is right for you,
I would recommend you
that you also have a look
what geography your
program is focusing on.
So if you, for instance, aim
to build a career for yourself
in the US after your MBA, it
would likely make lots of sense
to also do an MBA program,
which is in the US,
because this will help you
to build a deeper network
in the US if however, you'd
like to rather work in Asia,
probably doing an MBA
somewhere and that geography
might make more sense for you.
But especially the INSEAD
MBA for me is that one of the
distinguishing factors of
the INSEAD MBA experience
is that it wants to be an
especially international program,
so tries to really balance out the class.
There's no one dominating culture,
no one dominating geography in the class.
So we really have contacts
from literally all around the
world after you complete the program.
And this for me means now
pretty much doesn't matter
which country I want to visit
or which country I might
work in in the future,
there will be some
people who I can call up
and talk to them afterwards.
And this, of course, is
a great feeling not only
from the professional perspective,
but also from my private
and personal life.
The fourth key reason from
my perspective to do an MBA
is the cultural awareness that you build.
And again, this depends a bit
on what program you choose
what the profile of this program is,
but INSEAD was a highly
international program
and just meeting all these
people from that many cultures
really had a big positive
impact on my life.
During my MBA, I had the
opportunity to spend half the time
in the French campus,
but the other half also
in the Singapore campus.
So spend roughly half a
year in Asia in Singapore,
and it would be very typical.
And I heard this a lot from
people doing other MBA programs
as well so this is not only
specific to the INSEAD program,
but would be very typical
that almost every weekend,
there would be all kinds of
trips being organized by people
who are native of
different other countries
to then visit this country
with a bunch of other MBA friends,
so in the one year of my MBA
program, I was in Israel.
I was in Singapore, of
course, I was in Vietnam.
I was in Indonesia. I was in Thailand.
I spent two weeks with friends in India.
I was in China, I was in the US.
And this is just a selection
of all the countries
that I was in.
And to be honest, before I did the MBA,
as somebody who lived in Europe,
Asia was a pretty faraway place for me.
I was there a couple
of times for holidays.
But I really didn't have any
clue what Asia was all about.
But now after I've spent
half a year of my life
in Singapore, after I've
visited so many countries there
and I've met so many local
people during the MBA program,
this really opened up my
mind and I have a completely
different relationship with the continent
and I could very well imagine
to live there to work there
to spend my time there.
This really has helped me
a lot to better understand
this whole continent.
Though of course, it is clear
that given the diversity
of cultures and countries
on the continent,
whatever I have learned
can only be a brief scratch
of the surface.
And the last key advantage of
doing an MBA that I like to
share with you is that it
really is a time where it helps
you to self reflect on yourself,
on your goals and on your ambitions.
So while I was working at
McKinsey before the MBA,
there was really little time to rest.
And while I learned an
insane amount of things,
were working at McKinsey, there
was really little downtime,
really the time that allowed
me to just introspect,
to self-reflect, and to ask myself,
what the right move for
me as now going forward.
And the MBA really is
a great time for that.
Because it's not only that,
you will often have a bit
more time for yourself
than during your regular work.
But also given the fact that
you have all these inspirations
from the courses that you take
from the people that study
with you from the
countries that you visit.
All of these inspirations
really help you to take a step
back and ask yourself what
you really want what your
objectives are.
What you want to do in the future in this,
again helps you to make the
right decisions for you what you
wanna do after the MBA.
So guys, I was just out here on the run,
where I remember even another
reason even another advantage
of doing an MBA that I forgot
in this is that an MBA,
which were just the crazy
change of environment.
It can really help you reset your habits.
And what I mean by that,
just as an example, you know,
before the MBA when I
was working at McKinsey,
I really struggled with
sports, doing sports regularly,
who really, some really
struggled with sports,
but because of the change of environment,
because of all the new impressions
that I had during my MBA,
this really helped me to pick
up a regular running habit.
So I literally went
from not running at all
to running regularly.
And then shortly after the
MBA, I did a full marathon.
So 42 kilometers 26 miles,
which I did sub 4 hours which
was a great success for me.
And surely this would
have not had happened.
If I wouldn't have done the MBA.
And I mean just look at the environment.
These are just all the side products.
And this is also one of the
effects for me for sure.
That came out for me for the MBA.
So take care all of you
and enjoy have a good day.
So these are my five reasons
that after reflecting on myself
is what I think I got out of the MBA most
to this is not to say
that an MBA makes sense
for everyone.
So whether an MBA is
worthwhile for you depends on,
I think lots of factors
are outlined a few also
in the beginning regarding
the time investment
and the money investment.
But I hope this video helps
you make these deliberations
for your Senate, and also
hope to have added a few more
considerations and reasons which
maybe were not that obvious
for you when you were
thinking about doing an MBA.
So let me know in the comments below.
Do you already hold an MBA?
Are you thinking about doing
an MBA? What are your pros
and cons? Let's have a conversation there.
I'm going to answer to every
single comment that you write
if you took any value
out of this video at all.
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And of course, subscribe to
this channel to learn even more.
I'm going to release at least
one new video every Saturday.
And if you'd like to see
even more content for me,
follow me on Instagram under
the handle Firm Learning.
I'm posting new content pretty
much every day at the moment.
I hope you like it. Thank
you very much for watching.
I very much appreciate your time
hope you're all having a great weekend.
Stay safe and keep learning
everybody this is Heinrich
from Firm Learning. Bye there.